GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
PRESIDENT BIDEN BARELY LIFTING A
FINGER TO HELP A NATIONWIDE BABY
FORMULA SHORTAGE.
PARENTS ARE IN A FULL-BLOWN
PANIC OVER WHETHER THEY CAN KEEP
THEIR BABIES FROM STARVING.
SUPPLY IS DOWN 40% NATIONWIDE.
INSTEAD OF DEMANDING ACTION, ALL
BIDEN COULD MONSTER WAS A MEASLY
CLOSED PRESS EVENT B OF THE
PRESIDENT PUTTING OUT A
THREE-POINT PLAN TO ADDRESS THE
CRISIS VOWING TO CUT THE RED
TAPE.
JOE WAS APPARENTLY TOO BUSY TO
TALK DIRECTLY TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
AND AS USUAL WITH HIS
PRESIDENCY, IT BECOMES TOO
LITTLE, TOO LATE.
JEN PSAKI SPENDING LIKE CRAZY
APPEARS TO HAVE CONTRADICTED
HERSELF ON WHEN BIDEN LEARNED
ABOUT THE CRISIS.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS DIRECTED
THE ADMINISTRATION TO WORK
URGENTLY TO ENSURE THAT INFANT
FORMULA IS SAFE AND AVAILABLE
FOR FAMILIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THIS IS WORK THAT HAS BEEN
UNDERWAY FOR MONTHS.
>> WHEN WAS THE FIRST AM THE
PRESIDENT WAS BRIEFED?
>> I'M NOT TO GET INTO INTERNAL
BRIEFINGS.
THERE HAVE BEEN STEPS.
>> AS AMERICAN FAMILIES SCRAMBLE
TO KEEP THEIR BABIES FED, A
G.O.P. CONGRESSWOMAN MAKING A
BOMBSHELL CLAIM.
RELEASING PHOTOS SHE SAYS SHE
GOT FROM BORDER PATROL THAT
APPARENTLY SHOWS PALLETS OF HARD
TO FIND READY FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS TO USE.
>> THERE WERE SEVERAL AGENTS
THAT ACTUALLY SENT ME TEXT
MESSAGES WITH PHOTOS AND VIDEOS
OF NOT JUST BOXES, BUT PALLETS
OF UNOPENED, UNUSED, WAITING TO
BE USED BABY FORMULA AND
DIAPERS.
AND WE ARE TALKING LOTS OF
PALLETS.
THIS WAS AT THE DONNA PROCESSING
FACILITY AS WELL AS THE OTHER
FACILITY.
I HAVE IT FROM SEVERAL
HIGHER-UPS THAT MORE PALLETS ARE
EXPECTED TO ARRIVE IN THE NEXT
THREE DAYS.
>> WE DID REACH OUT TOYS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
FOR COMMENTS, BUT HAVEN'T HEARD
BACK.
ALL RIGHT, JESSE.
I GUESS NOW WE CAN ADD THE BABY
FOOD SHORTAGE TO THE LIST OF
OTHER DISASTER THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS DEALING WITH,
OR MAYBE NOT DEALING WITH.
ADD IT TO THE LAUNDRY LIST, YOU
HAVE TO SAY TO YOURSELF, IS THIS
JUST CONTINUOUSLY WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO DEAL WITH
WITHOUT ANYONE REALLY DOING
ANYTHING ABOUT IT?
>> THEIR SHORTAGES EVERYWHERE.
THERE IS ONE IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
BIDEN IS SO OLD SCHOOL HE
PROBABLY THINKS ALL WOMEN
BREASTFEED ANYWAY.
I'M SURPRISED HE HASN'T GONE
AFTER BIG FORMULA.
>> DON'T GO THERE.
>> THERE'S A FEW REASONS WHY.
THERE WAS A BABY BOOM POST
COVID, PEOPLE STARTED GETTING
DIZZY.
PEOPLE ARE STEALING THE BABY
FOOD BECAUSE YOU CAN SELL IT FOR
HIGH PRICES ON THE BLACK MARKET
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE RECALL,
THE SUPPLY CHAINS, AND THERE'S A
SHORTAGE OF LABOR AND COW MILK.
COW MILK INGREDIENTS THERE'S A
SHORTAGE OF IN THIS COUNTRY IN
2022.
DOES BIDEN SEE ANY OF THIS?
NO.
YESTERDAY WE PLAYED A SOUND BITE
SOUND BITE OF WHOOPI GOLDBERG
SAYING NONE OF THIS IS BIDEN'S
FAULT.
HE STEPS ON A LOOSE FLOORBOARD
THAT HIPS AND MEN HITS IN THE
FACE.
THEY CAN'T NAIL DOWN ANY OF THE
FLOORBOARDS.
EVERYTHING FROM BABY FORMULA,
CRIME, GAS PRICES, HE IS
SURPRISED BY.
THE MAN HAS NO VISION PRODUCED
LIKE A QUARTERBACK.
HE GETS UNDER THE CENTER AND HE
HAS NO IDEA HOW TO READ A
DEFENSE.
HE IS REACTING TO EVERYTHING.
YOU HAVE TO GET OUT THERE AND
ANTICIPATE THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING.
AT THIS POINT WHAT HE IS DONE
WITH FAMILIES, HE SAYS HE CARES
ABOUT CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
FIRST HE CALLS KIDS RACIST AND
SCHOOL, THEN HE CALLS PARENTS
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS, THAN THEY
CAN FEED THEIR BABIES, BUT WE
CAN FEED THE UKRAINIAN WAR
MACHINE.
WE CAN FEED THE ILLEGAL ALIEN
BABIES, BUT WE CAN'T FEED OUR
OWN BABIES?
IT'S SAD.
>> DOES NOT ADD TO THE AMERICA
LOST A THEME THAT IS GOING ON
SINCE JOE BIDEN BECAME
PRESIDENT?
WHAT THEY CONGRESSWOMAN SAYS IS
TRUE, AND I'VE NO REASON TO
DOUBT HER, THAT THERE IS -- I
SAID THE ON THE DAY ON THE SHOW,
LAST WEEK AND MY DAUGHTER'S
BABY, TEN MONTHS OLD, SHE SAID
MOM, CAN YOU GO LOOK FOR BABY
FORMULA?
TWO PLACES I WENT TO, NOTHING,
ZERO, AND NOW DO YOU KNOW HOW
FIRED UP I AM THAT THEY'VE GOT
THESE ON PALLETS AT THE BORDER?
WHAT ABOUT OUR KIDS?
>> IT IS NOT AMERICA LAST, IT IS
A SPECIFIC NUMBER OF OF AMERICA
LOST.
PERMISSION TO GO OFF?
THE GOVERNMENT DOESN'T LIKE HALF
OF THE PEOPLE THEY'VE GOVERNED.
ACTUALLY, IT MIGHT EVEN BE
HIGHER.
IT IS NOT JUST FROM PRESENT
REPUBLICANS.
WHITES, STRAIGHTS, MALES,
SUBURBAN MOMS.
THIS IS THE PARTY FOR THE
OPPRESSED.
EVEN IF YOU ARE A MOM WITH A
BABY, YOU ARE AN OPPRESSOR.
YOU REPRODUCE WHICH HARMS THE
ENVIRONMENT.
YOU EXPAND YOUR CARBON
FOOTPRINT.
YOU DIDN'T TERMINATE THE CHILD.
THERE IS NO BABY -- NO BABY
FORMULA THEY THINK IS NOT A BAD
THING.
JESSE IS RIGHT.
IF WE HAD AN ENGAGED PRESIDENT
WHO COULD SEE THE PRIORITIES OF
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN CLEARLY
INSTEAD OF RUNNING COVER FOR
WOKE POLICIES, WHETHER IT IS
CANCELING STUDENT DEBT,
DEFUNDING THE POLICE, THE
MEDICALIZATION OF CHILDREN, WE
WOULD HAVE BEATEN THIS THING OR
GOT A HEAD START ON THIS.
INSTEAD WE MAKE FUN OF HIM ABOUT
LOSING HIS KEYS, WHATEVER,
LOSING ITS PLACE, BUT HE'S KIND
OF LOST THE SENSE OF WHAT
AMERICA IS.
HE HAS FORGOTTEN THAT HE IS
PRESIDENT OF ALL OF US.
AND HE IS THE MOST SLOW TO REACT
PRESIDENT PROBABLY IN U.S.
HISTORY.
IT MIRRORS HIS OWN SLOW TO REACT
MANNERISMS.
AND WHEN HE IS CALLED OUT, HE
JUST STARTS YELLING.
IT IS A MANUFACTURED RAGE -- I
DO KNOW IF HE SAW THAT TAPE
YESTERDAY, IT IS A MANUFACTURED
RAGE.
IT IS A MAN SHOUTING AT THE
CLOUDS.
AND REALLY HAVING NO IDEA WHAT
TO DO.
AND I THINK THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
HAS EVERY RIGHT TO BE ENRAGED,
AND NOT THE KIND OF RAGE THAT
BURNS DOWN CITIES, WHICH IS
ACCEPTABLE TO SOME DEMOCRATS.
IN THIS CASE, YOUR KIDS GO
HUNGRY, YOU'RE GOING TO SEE MORE
THAN PARENTS.
>> GERALDO,
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
YESTERDAY HAD A VERY INTERESTING
ARTICLE.
THEY SAID THAT THIS RECALL AT
THE MANUFACTURING PLANT IN
MICHIGAN HAS WORKED IN AN
ALREADY EXISTING INDUSTRY WHERE
THEY'VE GOT A SHORTAGE OF BABY
FOOD.
BUT WHAT WAS STUNNING TO ME IN
THIS ARTICLE WAS THAT THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL SAYS
THAT THERE IS NO CONNECTION
BETWEEN ANYTHING AT THAT
MICHIGAN PLANT THAT HAS BEEN
CLOSED DOWN SINCE FEBRUARY 17TH
AND THE CHILDREN, THE TWO BABIES
WHO DIED AND TWO WHO WERE
INJURED.
THE QUESTION THAT I HAVE IS, IF
THE CDC SAYS THAT THERE IS NO
CONTAMINATION, ONE PERSON SET ON
FOX TODAY, I THINK IT WAS JAMES
FREEMAN, HE SAID IS THIS THE
GOVERNMENT CREATED SHORTAGE?
WHY DON'T THEY GO BACK IN AND
SAY, START PRODUCING?
>> IT MAY BE A GOVERNMENT
CREATED SHORTAGE, BUT I THINK IT
IS WRONG AND UNFAIR TO MINIMIZE
THE FACT THAT SIMILAC AND
ALUMINUM -- AND THE OTHER BABY
FORMULAS HAVE BEEN RECALLED.
THEY HAVE BEEN RECALLED.
THAT IS A FACT.
WHY WOULD THEY WERE CALLED?
BECAUSE KIDS GOT SICK, TWO OF
THE KIDS DIED OF BACTERIAL
INFECTIONS.
SO THERE'S SEVERAL THINGS THAT
GO ON.
NUMBER ONE, THE FDA WAS SLOW TO
REACT.
THEY GOT THE COMPLAINTS ABOUT
ABBOTT LABS IN OCTOBER.
IT WASN'T UNTIL THE END
OF JANUARY THAT THEY INSPECTED
THE ABBOTT PLANT.
WHISTLE-BLOWER AD ABBOTT HAS
ACCUSED THE MANUFACTURER OF
FAILING TO KEEP RECORDS,
RELEASING UNTESTED BABY FORMULA,
AND HOW DO THE RECORDS.
>> WHEN THEY TESTED -- THAT IS
THE ISSUE.
>> IT IS INTERESTING THAT
ABBOTT, IN SUPPORT OF WHAT YOU
SAID ABOUT THE CDC, ABBOTT IS
GIVING A NUMBER OUT THAT PEOPLE
CAN CALL AND I WILL LET THE
PRODUCERS TELL ME WHETHER I
SHOULD GIVE THE NUMBER, TO GET
THE BABY FORMULA FROM ABBOTT ON
THE ASSUMPTION THAT IT IS SAFE
ENOUGH.
THAT YOU WOULD RATHER FEED THE
BABY.
>> ARE YOU SAYING ABBOTT WOULD
GIVE PEOPLE FORMULA BASED ON A
NUMBER?
GIVE ME THE NUMBER.
FANTASTIC.
I DO KNOW -- WHAT I WANT TO DO
IS I WANT TO GO TO YOU.
THE OTHER THING I THOUGHT WAS
VERY UNUSUAL IS THAT 98% OF THE
FORMULA THAT WE USE IN THIS
COUNTRY FOR BABIES, AND BY THE
WAY, IF YOU ARE NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THIS, IF YOU DON'T HAVE
KIDS, YOU CAN'T JUST GIVE THE
BABY'S FOOD.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE FORMULA.
YOU CAN'T MAKE IT.
APPARENTLY WE SELL THAT FORMULA
TO OTHER COUNTRIES.
WE PULL BACK AND SAY IT IS
AMERICA FIRST?
IS THAT WHAT JOE BIDEN SHOULD BE
DOING?
>> ONE THING THAT THE FDA SHOULD
HAVE DONE AND IS PLANNING TO DO
ACCORDING TO THE TALKING POINTS
THAT THEY WERE REGURGITATED
TODAY IS ALLEVIATING SOME OF THE
TRADE RESTRICTIONS THAT THE FDA
HAS IN PLACE ON FORMULA.
WHY DID THEY WAIT?
BECAUSE THE SHORTAGES WERE GOING
UP, AND UP, AND UP.
WEEK AFTER WEEK, MONTH AFTER
MONTH.
THIS IS NOT JUST AN ABBOTT
PROBLEM.
THERE WERE SUPPLY PROBLEMS ON
FORMULA MONTHS AND MONTHS
BEFORE.
LAST MONTH, APRIL 10TH, THE WEEK
OF APRIL 10TH, 31% OF THE MOST
POPULAR FORMULA BRANDS WERE OUT
OF STOCK.
THE WEEK OF APRIL 24TH, IT WAS
UP TO 40%.
SO JEN PSAKI HAS THE GALL TO
STAND UP THERE AND SAY, WE HAVE
KNOWN ABOUT THAT FOR MONTHS.
OKAY, SEE YOU KNEW ABOUT IT FOR
MONTHS AND DIDN'T DO ANYTHING?
AND FRIGHTEN THESE PARENTS AND
POTENTIALLY LET CHILDREN STARVE
WAS TO MARK THAT EAR AMERICA?
IF YOU KNEW ABOUT IT FOR MONTHS,
SO THE FDA IS GOING TO RELIEVE
SOME OF THESE REGULATIONS BARELY
SEEMS TO BE THE BROAD PROBLEM
FOR BIDEN INCORPORATED.
THERE IS A MANDATE THAT
RETAILERS HAVE TO WAIT 90 DAYS
BEFORE MARKETING A NEW INFANT
FORMULA.
WHY DOES THAT EXIST WHEN THERE
ARE VAST SHORTAGES IN THIS
COUNTRY?
SO THERE WERE FOUR BABIES WHO
GOT SICK, TWO OF WHOM HAVE DIED,
AND IT TOOK THEM -- THEY HAVE AN
EVEN RESTART AT THE PLANT, IT IS
TWO WEEKS FROM NOW.
WHY WAS THE FDA AND THE CDC
AND -- THEY WERE DRAGGING THEIR
FEET ABOUT THIS WHEN THE FORMULA
SHORTAGES WERE GETTING HORACE.
>> SHE SAYS OH, WE ARE TRACKING
IT.
WHO CARES IF YOU ARE TRACKING
IT?
>> I WANT TO ADD ONE MORE THING.
THE BACTERIAL INFECTIONS WERE
NOT TRACED TO THAT PLANT,
PERIOD.
BIDEN -- THEY LIVE IN A WORLD
THAT DOESN'T EXIST THAT THEY
WANT TO EXIST.
THEY DON'T LIVE IN THE REAL
WORLD.
THEY ARE TRYING TO CREATE THIS
LEFT-WING LAND OF OF THE LAW